Hey Chris.
How you feeling about
the earthquake app so far?
>> You know, pretty good.
We covered a lot last lesson, and
the app's looking pretty slick.
>> It does look very slick.
However we only pretended that we got
a list of the earthquakes from the USGS.
>> True.
>> We just copy and pasted the data
that we got from the web browser and
hard coded it as a string into our app.
>> Right.
>> In this lesson, lesson two,
we're going to learn about networking,
which is an exchange of information that
happens between computers
over the Internet.
>> Yeah, this is a powerful concept
because you'll be able to request data
from anywhere on the Internet and
display it on your phone.
>> Networking is
a fairly advanced topic.
So if it sounds a little scary,
don't worry.
There are semester-long college
courses that cover only the subject.
The main goal here is that you'll
have more questions about how these
things work.
>> Yeah, and we don't want you to get
overwhelmed with all the details.
So we're going to provide you with just
enough information at just the right
time so you'll understand
the high level process and
how to write the Android
code to make it happen.
>> Dude, we should tell
them about the Soonami app.
>> Yeah, we totally should.
Well, it helps to work with
a working version of networking code
before you write it yourself.
So in this lesson,
we're going to be using a sample
app called the Soonami app.
The Soonami app uses the same
USGS API as the Quake Report app, but
with a slightly different use case,
showing whether or
not a particular Soonami alert was
issued for a particular earthquake.
In this lesson, you'll practice reading
and understanding how the Soonami app
makes an HTTP request to the USGS
service and receives a response back.
>> Yeah, so just to be clear, the
Soonami app is meant to prepare you so
you can write the networking code
on your own in the QuakeReport app
in lesson three.
This is going to be good,
let's get started.